[Narrator:] Every town. The town in which
you and I live. In the North, South, East, or West.
Our homes. Our work. Our recreations make
Everytown what it is.
Every town is on the move, swinging in the rhythm of these United States.
Yes, in Everytown, happiness and security are challenged daily by an enemy.
This enemy strikes oftenest at you. His name is tuberculosis.
Here is a germ that causes this disease. All
of us in Everytown bear the burden of tuberculosis.
But it weighs heaviest on those whose loved
ones it attacks and often kills.
Tuberculosis blasts the hope of parents.
Parents who have made uncounted sacrifices for their children.
Tuberculosis, maker of orphans.
[ Music ]
Everytown teems with industry. In the [?] home,
the enemy and his victims are easily forgotten.
The youth of Everytown glory in their strength;
their zest for life. Yet tuberculosis destroys
32,000 Americans under 40 each year.
Here is Roy. He is young. He is strong. He
is unafraid. He has heft and red blood.
And here, in another of Everytown's many industries
is Julie. Eager and capable.
[Bell rings]
Yet that quitting bell has a welcome sound
when the day's work is done.
[ Music ]
Life now really begins for Julie. Roy feels
the same way about his whistle blast.
Romance begins for Julie and Roy when they
meet at the factory door.
The old jalopy coughs and snorts, but it still goes places.
To the rainbow for instance. A rosy rainbow
of promise.
[ Music ]
The young Americans in Everytown who work hard, play hard, too. Gaiety, fun, companionship.
These are products of normal, Everytown life.
[ Music ]
Roy and Julie wouldn't miss their holiday
swim for anything. Building health and strength
in the fresh air. Carefree and happy.
[ Music ]
Hello? What is this?
A hemorrhage from the lung?
[Bell ringing]
Everytown's health guardians are on the job
ready to serve any and all.
Luckily for Roy, there's a first-rate sanatorium
in Everytown.
Blood from the mouth, the physician knows,
is not to be passed up lightly. Experienced
Experienced hands, skilled eyes and ears, track down the cause of that hemorrhage.
Gets the facts together. All the odds and ends of facts.
Sputum and blood samples are taken, and off they go to the laboratory.
[ Music ]
And very important, the magic eye of the x-ray.
Only a shadow picture is produced, but the
trained eye can read what's behind those shadows
as clearly as you read the page of a book.
The sputum sample is put through a rigid test.
The microscope aids.
The germ: unmistakable.
To the medical staff, these facts spell tuberculosis
of the left lung. Active, far advanced,
and with a cavity.
But if Roy plays the game, his chances are
good. Treatment. Absolute bed rest.
And, says the Chief of Staff, "Bring this case up for review in one month."
Tuberculosis certainly changes Roy's life.
It puts a sudden stop to work and play and plans for the future.
[ Music ]
Rest and more rest. Rest for Roy, but not
for the case-finders.
Every town's health workers know that each case of tuberculosis comes from some other case.
Public health nurses inquire, from whom did
Roy get it? To whom has he given it?
Find out from his employer about his workmates.
Is someone there who gave the disease to him?
Is there someone else to whom Roy may have given it?
This is how the germ gets from one body to
another. Now, thorough but careful detective work
finds out about Roy's home, his work,
his close associates.
The nurse follows every clue. Roy's friends
are interested.
Here comes a clue easy to follow. Julie, where does she live?
This nurse is a contact finder. Do you remember Julie?
[ Music ]
That was lip contact. The surest way of transporting
tuberculosis germs.
Don't delay, Julie. Let the doctor decide.
Then Julie visits her physician. Besides a
routine examination of the chest, the examination
includes the tuberculin test.
A simple skin test which tells whether tuberculosis
germs have found a foothold in the body.
Up-to-date physicians everywhere now use this test.
If negative, it means no tuberculosis. If
positive, it means search further.
[ Music ]
Julie returns. The test is positive.
The spot where the solution was injected is slightly raised and reddish.
Julie must be x-rayed.
Here are the shadows.
Expertly interpreted by her doctor, they say
early tuberculosis.
Don't delay Julie, the sooner treatment is
begun, the more certain the cure.
Bed rest now for Julie.
Almost a vegetable existence it is, but reading
helps. Good reading habits help Julie, as
they have so many others, to readjust her life. A friendly place, the sanatorium.
[ Music ]
The medical chief talks to all of the patients.
By such means, modern sanatoria educate their
patients in a new way of life. Listen in with
all the patients to what the doctor says.
Our sanatorium is but one of the many base
hospitals of a great warfare. Here we train
doctors, nurses, technical workers who carry
on the battle.
The sanatorium is a place to care for sick
people and restore them to a useful life.
Here the resources of medical science are
put into practice in the treatment of the
patient, and the defeat of tuberculosis.
Outside our sanatorium are other forces. Health
departments. Health workers.
Educators who plan the strategy.
The Tuberculosis Association brings the story
of tuberculosis to the public by printed matter,
on the picture screen, over the air.
Throughout the country, tuberculosis associations
backed up by the National Tuberculosis Association
are in every town to make war on the enemy.
For the physician, technical publications.
For the public, clearly written information.
All of this made possible by the sale of Christmas
Seals.
Julie listens and learns. Someday she will
become one of the soldiers fighting tuberculosis.
But first comes the business of getting better,
and that means rest.
What news of Roy after weeks of bed rest?
The x-ray shadows tell Roy's doctor that the
cavity in the lung is still open. The germs
are still in his sputum.
He needs special treatment.
The doctor arranges for Roy a simple operation
called pneumothorax.
A local anesthetic comes first.
[ Music ]
Very gently, air is allowed to enter between
the rigid chest wall and the soft lung tissue.
By means of a series of these simple operations,
the diseased lung is compressed long enough to heal.
Meanwhile, Roy's doctor calls a staff meeting to study Roy as a person.
The librarian reports what he reads.
The occupational therapist explores Roy's
interests.
And the nurse? Roy's heart interest is no
secret to his nurse.
From the state rehabilitation agent, the doctor learns more about Roy's former job.
He must give this up, too. The whole trained
staff helps the doctors to understand Roy
and his problems. Time brings improvement.
This earns new privileges for Roy.
The state rehabilitation agent knows about
jobs and training for jobs.
Roy's doctor calls on this knowledge to help plan a new life for Roy.
First, Roy needs to know himself.
How fast and how accurately can Roy do clerical work?
Does he have mechanical aptitude? How readily
does he see patterns, size, design?
How well do Roy's two hands work together?
Has he much knack for handling small tools?
The answers to such questions [break in audio]
Roy a lot about himself. Now the doctor couples
what he knows about Roy with what the rehabilitation
agent knows of jobs and training.
Together they discuss various occupations.
A final rehabilitation plan is worked out with and for Roy.
The rehabilitation agent and Roy's former
employer work out a retraining plan in a growing industry.
Roy continues to improve.
He earns further privileges.
Ahh, what a privilege it is after months in bed, just to amble out of doors.
However, leisure should not mean idleness.
Roy learns new forms of play more suitable to his condition.
A man's hobbies may have much to do with his health.
And then there's Julie.
For what job shall
Julie be trained? Homemaking is a job too.
Keeping house efficiently spares energy and
saves money.
Julie will need her energy to keep well.
A smooth-running job even in housekeeping is less tiring. Her doctor knows that well.
So Julie is taught how to avoid hard ways
in homemaking.
One can learn to work more efficiently.
Roy's day of graduation from the sanatorium
comes at last.
[Music]
And it's goodbye to the sanatorium. But Roy takes with him what he has learned.
Rehabilitation now goes ahead full speed.
[ Music ]
Medical checkup is not neglected. The healed
lung holds firm.
Roy's training is checked by the rehabilitation agent.
It leads to a job. Roy has been helped to
prepare for a job he can do.
[Bell ringing]
The road back, always long and often tedious,
leads at last to happiness.
[ Music ]
Roy and Julie. They have found the way back.
The war against tuberculosis goes on in every town.
Their close escape from disaster makes new
recruits of Roy and Julie. They have seen
active service as casualties.
[ Music ]
They seek reenlistment with all who aid defense against tuberculosis.
Their experience may help other young people to avoid disaster.
Their interest will last for the duration of the war.
[ Music ]
Citizens of Everytown enlist! Wipe out tuberculosis
in Everytown!
[ Music ]